got it and towns is on the floor looks  like he's holding there is right knee or  calf area  he took a hit last night and he was able  to come back into the game we'll take a  look at what happened here but at the  moment Carl Anthony towns getting help  to his feet  goes down in the heat helped off the  floor did not put any pressure on that  right leg he reached and that calf area  as he looked to push off there  [Music]  he's back in the locker room getting  treatment  get an update when we can but  really unfortunate seeing towns helped  off the floor  93-76 here's the end of the play where  you see him come up limp right there  true I'm not going to speculate  that's not good yeah Carl was helped  in the back by the medical trainers  to get an update soon but  you know